the lore of physics has it that in 1589
Galileo dropped different masses from
the Leaning Tower of Pisa
to demonstrate that all objects
regardless of their constitution
accelerate at the same rate towards the
Earth
an experiment which would help Inspire
Newton's laws of gravity
but it would take over 300 years and a
little prodding from Einstein
for physics to realize that this
interpretation was wrong
indeed if Newton and the theorists of
his era had looked a little more deeply
into their own laws
they might have realized that it was
Galileo the Tower of Pisa and the ground
that were accelerating up all along
this is dialect with
the sky is falling up
ordinary intuition from our everyday
experience tells us that Things fall
down
apples
water
sometimes people
so naturally when we attempt to describe
the laws of nature at a place like the
surface of the Earth we try first and
foremost to fit those laws to such
intuitions
and indeed this is exactly what Newton
did in attributing the falling of
everyday objects to the universal force
of gravity
but sometimes ordinary intuition is a
pretty bad guide and it can take a
little deeper reasoning to sort the
truth out
take the concept of time for instance
classical physics defined time as a
mathematical absolute
doing so because this was in keeping
with everyday intuition
but some philosophers weren't happy with
the assumption that all clocks
everywhere must tick at the same rate
and they asked that an empirical
operative definition be instead given to
the concept of time
that is they demanded that clocks and
time be defined via an experiment which
could actually be physically carried out
rather than assumed via a mathematical
abstraction
after Einstein provided exactly the
specifications for such an operative
definition of time in his 1905 Landmark
paper
the theory of special relativity was
born
and in consequence time was shown to be
a rather extraordinary counter-intuitive
phenomenon
likewise applying an operative
definition to the concept of length
shows that space itself does not conform
to our everyday intuitions
but what happens if we apply an
operative definition to the concept of
motion
specifically acceleration
indeed not long after developing special
relativity Einstein himself considered
this question in the context of asking
whether a man falling off a building
could measure his own weight
well it turns out there are a number of
operative definitions you can give to
accelerated motion
and indeed you can apply them right here
at the surface of the Earth
but only if you're ready to accept their
astounding implications
[Music]
as it is written in his principia
naturalis Newton's first law states that
every body perseveres in its state of
rest or of uniform motion in a right
line
unless it is compelled to change that
state by forces impressed thereupon
[Music]
now in conjunction with Newton's Second
Law which relates Force to acceleration
this implies an obvious way to detect
true motion
by measuring whether a body deviates
from rectilinear uniform motion
let's apply this to an observer on a
rocket ship
who say is unaware of their state of
motion
to try to determine it they toss an
object off of themselves
if this object floats away with uniform
motion then from Newton's first law they
can deduce that the frame of the rocket
ship is inertial
I.E that it's at rest or moving with
constant velocity
this is like what you see with
astronauts in zero gravity environments
when they're floating around looking all
cool and whatnot
now if our Observer tosses the object
off themselves and it instead falls to
the ground then Newton's Laws now imply
that a force must be involved
one that either accelerated the object
to the ground
or one that accelerated the ground to
the object
if this Observer is equipped with
sufficient prior knowledge of their
system
foreign
knows that their object contains no
internally acting forces
and isn't magnetically attracted to the
floor or anything of that sort meaning
that it is a free body
they can rule out the possibility that
the object was acted upon by a local
Force
that leaves a second possibility
that the object never accelerated at all
and rather it was the floor of the
rocket ship that accelerated up to meet
it
note here that this would give rise to
an apparent downward motion of the
object even though its true motion
remained a uniform line
at least until it gets hit by the floor
thus The Observer now has an operative
definition for motion that is they have
an experiment by which to define whether
their frame is accelerating or not
this is the free body test
foreign
The Observer might also have used an
accelerometer in the form of something
such as masses attached to a spring
or they could have relied on haptic
input from their nervous system
both of which are essentially more
sophisticated reformulations of the free
body test
okay now let's have our Observer put
such definitions into practice at the
surface of the Earth
[Music]
um
first they take a loose object and toss
it off themselves
what happens well just like on the
accelerating rocket ship it falls to the
ground
next they use an accelerometer masses
attached to a spring
they notice that the spring compresses
again just like on the rocket ship
next they use their nervous system to
feel their own weight
and they notice they feel just as heavy
as being on a rocket ship accelerating
at 9.8 meters per second squared through
space
in fact all and every experiment they
perform at the surface of the Earth will
give indistinguishable results from
being on an accelerating rocket ship
the next question then naturally is what
is an observer allowed to conclude from
this
well an objection that could be raised
from the get-go is that the free body
test can't be performed at the surface
of the Earth because the body isn't free
at all
rather it's being acted upon by the
downward force of gravity
so unlike when we were in the rocket
ship here we can't rule out the
possibility that a force acted locally
to accelerate our object to the ground
as to the other possibility that the
ground accelerated up well this doesn't
seem to fit with our everyday intuition
nor with the larger picture of the Earth
being round and all
so we like Newton probably feel pretty
comfortable declaring at this point that
the reason the Apple falls to the Earth
is in fact because of the force of
gravity
[Music]
alas there's something that throws a
huge wrench into this idea
the same varies something that Galileo
demonstrated with his Tower of Pisa
experiments all those centuries ago
it's the fact that gravity accelerates
all objects equally meaning there is no
such thing as a body free from the
gravitational force
mutually charged objects are free from
the electromagnetic force
but no object can ever serve as the
standard of our definition of a free
body in a gravitational field
thus we have at once lost the very thing
we set out to construct a definition for
true motion
because now our Observer on the rocket
ship has no way to distinguish whether
it was the floor that accelerated
towards their object
or whether they're simply in the
presence of a gravitational field which
has rendered their free body not so free
after all
even worse with no way to make such a
distinction motion seems to lose its
meaning
an observer accelerating in a car for
instance has equal right to say that
they are motionless because they can
just claim there is a sideways directed
gravitational field in their proximity
acting to accelerate every loose object
towards the back of the vehicle
this fact is encapsulated by what's
known as the equivalence principle
which as Einstein put it is the physical
equivalence between a homogeneous
gravitational field and an accelerated
frame of reference
now over the decades the equivalence
principle has been interpreted by many
as indicating that there is in fact no
difference between true and apparent
motion
that they are interchangeable via the
addition or subtraction of a
gravitational field
such a view is purported for instance by
Eugene carteriansky in his twin paradox
video
but this interpretation neglects an
extremely important caveat to the
equivalence principle
namely that it applies only locally
that is over very small regions of space
and short durations of time
this means it is not true that no
experiment can distinguish between a
uniform gravitational field and
acceleration
indeed if we are willing to give our
observer in the car a little more
latitude in their measurement takings
there is an additional experiment they
can perform to determine if their motion
is real or apparent
that is after a few seconds they can
take their foot off the accelerator
when they do this they will notice that
the gravitational field in their
vicinity instantaneously vanishes
the instantaneity is key here because
according to the theory of special
relativity nothing can travel faster
than the speed of light
The Vanishing of the gravitational field
thus cannot be attributable to any real
counteractive Force
meaning the observer in the car must
conclude the field was fictitious
this means at last we can establish a
test for true motion
here's how
if there exists some local switch we can
find to make a gravitational field in
our immediate vicinity
instantaneously vanish
then we know that in fact this
gravitational field cannot have been
real and that previously we had been
undergoing true motion
in the case of the car the switch is the
accelerator pedal
in the case of the rocket it's the
firing of the rocket engines
now in a similar manner let's ask is
there something we can do at the surface
of the Earth to instantaneously switch
off the gravitational field there
because if we can indeed find such a
switch this will distinguish for us
whether the force causing all objects to
fall down is a real one
or rather if it is merely an apparent
one caused by an erroneous Judgment of
motion from an accelerated frame of
reference
it turns out there is such a switch what
is it exactly
well go to the top of a tall building
and step off of it
the instant you step off the building
the gravitational field in your
immediate vicinity
instantaneously vanishes
or as Einstein wrote ceases to exist
you can prove this to yourself by
performing the free body test for
inertial motion as you fall
just like the unaccelerated observer in
the rocket ship you will discover that
neglecting air resistance if you toss
objects off yourself while falling these
objects will float away with uniform
motion
carry a spring with you it won't
compress
try to weigh yourself on a scale and
you'll get a reading of zero
according to Newton's Laws you therefore
must conclude that your frame of
reference is inertial and that you are
not accelerating
yet if you look down the Earth is
definitely getting closer and closer
but if you aren't accelerating this
leaves one and only one logical
possibility it is the earth that is
accelerating towards you
go to any spot in a gravitational field
and you can always find a way to make
the field vanish in your immediate
vicinity
jump a few feet up in the air off the
ground and this action immediately
causes a Vanishing of the force field
around you
and just like with The Disappearance of
the force fields in the car or the
rocket
this Vanishing indicates you are no
longer undergoing accelerated motion
and when your feet hit the ground again
The Field's instantaneous faster than
the speed of light reappearance
indicates your accelerated motion has
resumed
indeed anywhere you do observe a
gravitational field then is simply a
sign that your frame of reference is
accelerating
[Music]
this means that nowhere do gravitational
fields actually exist and that gravity
in its Newtonian conception is entirely
a fiction
at the surface of the Earth then nothing
truly ever Falls rather the ground the
trees the buildings and the sky itself
are continually accelerating upwards at
9.8 meters per second squared towards
anything that might happen to be in
their way
you may be inclined to scoff at all this
how can the Earth accelerate in every
direction at once
if the ground Falls up towards an apple
in North America
then this means everything at the
opposite end of the Earth must be
falling into the sky
well there is one important fact left to
mention and it's that only uniform
gravitational fields can be made to
wholly vanish using the switch method
and though a gravitational field like
what you see at the surface of the Earth
is very nearly uniform there is a slight
decrease in the strength of the field as
we go higher up
as well as a slight radially inwards
rotation of the field direction as we
move laterally outwards
so for our Observer who steps off the
building roof what actually vanishes for
them is the uniform component of this
field
now for every point of The observed
gravitational field there's a vector
corresponding to the strength and
direction of the field there
the component which vanishes then is
precisely the one corresponding to the
vector at the center of the free-falling
Observer
to find what remains of the true
gravitational force then
we must subtract this Vector everywhere
from the field
doing this towards the top of the frame
where the field is weaker will find a
small upwards pointing Force left over
doing it towards the bottom of the frame
where the field is stronger leaves a
small downwards pointing Force left over
lastly towards either side we'll find
small inwards directed forces left over
these are the tidal forces or real
gravity
we can't make a traditional force field
out of them
but unlike the downward directed
gravitational force these tidal forces
can't be transformed away
moreover they can be detected
if the Observer free falling off the
building has precise enough measuring
equipment with them they will notice
that objects towards the edge of their
frame will slowly start to deviate from
rectilinear motion and begin to move
together
contrarily objects towards the top and
bottom of the frame will slowly move
apart
indeed it's these title forces that
from a global standpoint
are ultimately responsible for the
attraction between bodies in general
relativity
however at a place like the surface of
the Earth
these tidal forces are so incredibly
small that they are only responsible for
an imperceptible fraction of the
attraction of an object towards the
ground
the rest of that attraction is entirely
due to the ground hurtling up towards
the object at 9.8 meters per second
squared
[Music]
that is why indeed it is entirely
factual to say that the sky is falling
up
all this requires a great deal of
suspension of ordinary intuition
but we promise that once you start to
see things this way the theory of
general relativity begins to make a
whole lot more sense
moreover such an understanding opens the
door to What's called the river model of
general relativity wherein we can
picture mass and energy to be
continually sucking space inwards like a
vacuum or a drain
but that's all for future videos
for now just trust us that all your
lingering questions will be answered
this has been dialect thanks for
watching
foreign
[Music]